[Музика]
привіт, хлопці, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звуть Наталія лікер і мене
звуть о, давай, мамо, давайте розпочнемо
урок, тому сьогодні ми продовжимо розмову
про наше тіло та про те, що дає нам енергію
та їжу  їжа, давайте подивимося, чи добре ти
засвоїла урок Наталія, давайте
перевіримо, у мене є дуже відома цитата, але
я все переплутався, я бачу, так що
для мене це складний виклик так, давайте подивимося, що ви з цього
зробите добре, скажімо, у мене різні
слова їсти що  ти є і ще один ти
добре, тому мені потрібно сформулювати фразу так,
будь ласка,
гм, ти їси, ти, ти, це добре
так,
коли ви чуєте цю фразу, ви те, що
ви їсте, що ви думаєте про що ви думаєте, я думаю,
це щось про вашу улюблену
їжу
так ах яка ваша улюблена їжа в
шоколадній макароні, сир, а як
щодо газованих напоїв кола
так, я дуже люблю газовані напої  так, на
попередньому уроці ми говорили про п’ять
основних  категорії давайте подивимося, чи
пам'ятає їх Наталія моя подруга, добре, ще один
виклик для мене, тож давайте, це було
слово так, будь ласка,
це перше так, ви
бачите Lexus на екрані, так що
розшифруйте зі мною давайте я бачу
Latsis це  Схоже, слово фрукти
та овочі ступінь
добре, тепер давайте напишемо їх правильно, щоб VE
отримати BL es невдалий Аббас і
давайте з фруктами, а ви, ig, а ми, фрукти
та овочі,
добре зроблені в нашій піраміді, який
буде шар номер два
так шар номер два давайте шукаємо
інші шари, давайте, добре, це
наступний, скажімо, що це легко, це жири,
тому давайте палітру F a T є і це
була остання група правильно так мінімальна
кількість мінімальна мм-хм добре давайте
йдіть далі, щоб я бачу n oh I PE t виглядає як
протеїн, ви згодні зі мною добре, давайте
напишемо це PR примітка я та виправте так,
протеїн приклад білка давайте перейдемо
до наступного,
я бачу багато літер ах це
слово я не  Не подобається це велике  gest
group це складні слова
вуглеводи добре давайте з
літерами C a є B Oh H чому D є TE
дупа правильно Ольга так вуглеводи
вуглеводи добре і останнє чи можете
ви згадати, що було останнє, я
думаю, ми маємо на увазі останній  одна, яка є
Dairy Dairy, ви маєте рацію, фантастична,
давайте, тому ми маємо G a I наш, і чому
так,
багато моїх учнів роблять помилку,
змішуючи молочні та молочні продукти, так,
ми подивилися на це на попередньому уроці так, так,
правильний  молочні продукти, поки
щоденник є десь, де ти пишеш свій
секретний соус, правильно, так, Ольга,
ти мене випробувала, зараз я збираюся перевірити
Ольгу, тому назви їжу з категорії
молочні молоко йогурт Ісус і
сир мій улюблений добре фантастичний
давайте  іди ми поштримуємо кнопку фрукти Ой
банани яблука огірки помідори
манго та баклажани фантастично
які ваші слова, хлопці, я люблю банани і
ягоди також
прийшло давайте переглянемо білкову групу
чи пам'ятаєте слова Ольга, допоможіть нам
цим  було б риба птиця
птиця курка і качки
і м'ясо правильно червоне м'ясо належатиме сюди,
однак я пам'ятаю, ви казали мені уникати
червоного м'яса j2 через багато жиру, корисного,
і давайте переглянемо групу жирів О,
це було б масло оливкове  олія
соняшникова олія добре так,
хлопці, ви бачите зображення на своєму
екрані, і ми даємо вам дві хвилини, щоб
позначити зображення
[Музика]
[Музика],
тому ми повернулися, і у Ольги є
запитання до мене так,
зараз час обіду  що б ви зазвичай
їли, якщо б ви голодні, подивіться тут
о ні, чому це смачна їжа, чи це
буде сьогодні обід, щось на
кшталт перекусу, не обіду, а перекусу
так трохи чіпсів я люблю їх
газований напій я сказав тобі, що дай  дає
мені багато енергії і підтримує мене в живих і
цукерки, звісно, снеки Вау, це
огано, це зовсім не здорово Наталія, ти
ачиш, спробуй розділити це на групи, це
удуть жири, олії, жири і ц
кор, ну добре, щоб я міг легко  залишимо
без чіпсів, тож залишимо
чіпси  десь там добре, тож, ймовірно, газований
напій теж не дуже корисний, тому я можу
легко замінити його водою, так,
особливо якщо ви вважаєте, що газований
напій дає вам енергію, але ми вивчали
з вами, тоді це не газований напій
і цукор дають вам енергію
вуглеводи фантастичні, так що цукерки, хм,
це те, що я не можу уникнути,
я люблю цукерки-салах, снек-бари, кажуть, чи можемо
ми все-таки їсти це, але якщо я буду готувати це зі
здорової їжі, це буде добре
здорова їжа здорові цукерки так,
цікаво, що це
Тож давайте готувати разом вони корисні
цукерки я навчу вас, як це робити
добре,
тож давайте перевіримо інгредієнти, які нам
потрібні, допоможіть мені Ольга
правильно я бачу багато сухих ягід мм-хм
я бачу горіхи більше ягід говорить мм
-Хм і кокос, так, добре, кажу, що це
буде нашими основними інгредієнтами, тому у нас є
горіхи,
це мигдаль, добре, і у нас також є
сушені вишні, добре, і давайте подивимося на
цю тарілку, у нас є три різних
типи сушених ягід, чи можу я здогадатися  що
це, о, це родзинки, мій улюблений,
добре,
це також родзинки. Вау, вони
просто з іншого сорту винограду,
ймовірно, це стейк, і ви вгадаєте
цей.
О, журавлина так, вони смачні,
добре, тож давайте приготуємо для цього
потрібні цукерки  кухонний комбайн наш кухонний
комбайн готовий, тому ми просто кладемо
всі інгредієнти сюди та збираємося
змішувати їх, тому слідкуйте за нами, хлопці, я
просто додам усі інгредієнти сюди, а
ви готуєте це на око, а не
потрібно виміряти його, просто додайте стільки, скільки
хочете, добре, тому я поклав його всередину, і ви
всі назвали його хороша
журавлина добре родзинки гарні два
види родзинок добре білий родзинки
для чорного родзинок фантастичний родзинки
тут ви любите вишні
так  сухі вишні, і вони виглядають дуже
гарно так, ви любите вишні добре,
давайте додамо їх, скільки вам потрібно
ціла пляшка або половина, вони
солодкі чи кислі, я кажу, що можу сказати, що напівсолодкі,
добре, тоді я піду на все  добре
давайте все  e bowl
так добре тітонька виграй так горіхи мигдаль,
як ти сказав, то давайте покладемо їх усі так, щоб
домовитися так добре, які горіхи ви
знаєте, хлопці, ви знаєте чи будь-які горіхи
olga ah волоський горіх добре фундук кешью
кешью так добре, тому я
збираюся змішувати цю суміш, поки я змішую, подивіться
на екран і перегляньте види горіхів, наше
тісто готове, о, вау, але, схоже,
ми забули додати ці інгредієнти,
ці інгредієнти, які ми збираємося використовувати
для заправки, тож давайте викладемо нашу суміш
сюди  в мисці вам потрібна для
цього ложка, зараз все буде так
, все готово
, ви помили руки, хлопці, завжди
мийте руки перед тим, як почати готувати,
так що це наше тісто готове, і нам
потрібно сформувати цукерки так  ви просто
візьміть ложку і візьміть трохи тіста,
давай, агар, добре, він працює як
пластилін, тому почніть готувати, ви можете
сформувати куб або коло я піду з
кубиком, ви можете піти з колом так, я
піду з колом, виглядайте красивий
куб  красиві кола і я гой  ng, щоб
додати це до кокосу вау, чи можу я
використовувати пори року так, будь ласка, так,
це зроблено Вау, виглядає смачно, так, я працюю над своїм,
зараз моя виглядає дуже смачно,
давайте перейдемо з різними формами так,
я піду на піраміду, оскільки ми говорили
про харчові піраміди
я  створюю пірамідки з цукерок я
піду з формою ковбаски добре, а цього
разу я піду з сесом так о добре давайте поміняємось так
кокос моя піраміда
готова давайте ще дві добре добре
я збираюся зробити сердечко і  Я
зроблю ромбовидну форму. Ви тримаєте їх
у холодильнику після приготування. Так, ви можете
покласти їх у морозилку та використовувати
їх як закусочну пізніше.
У мене форма ромба готова. Я маю
ідею, що це може бути прекрасним подарунком для
мій друг фантастично, якщо ти помістиш їх у
гарну коробку, звичайно так,
так давайте відкриваємо сезон фантастично, мій
діамант готовий так, моє серце готове -
фантастично, хлопці, тепер ви бачите рецепт
на екрані, тож давайте переглянемо, що нам
потрібно Наталія, я дійсно дійсно  подобається твій
рецепт  проте я боюся,
що в Греції я не маю вдома, це нормально,
ви можете використовувати інгредієнти, які у вас
є вдома, я сказав вам, що ви можете використовувати
різні види нешвейцарського кешью з
волоськими горіхами з мигдалем будь-що, що у вас
є  вдома, і ви також можете замінити
сушеною вишнею, я б підійшов фініками -
як фініки, так, я люблю фініки і
курагу, курага - це дев'ять, будьте
обережні з чорносливом, тому що він має
дуже сильний смак,
якщо ви його не любите, не любите  використовуйте його нормально,
і завжди додавайте до нього родзинки. Сушені
вишні можуть надати трохи
кислинки, але ви також можете додати трохи лимонного
соку, щоб зробити його соковитим, чи можу я ще
раз уточнити у вас, як довго я можу
покласти його в морозилку в  морозильник,
це буде приблизно 12 годин,
це найкращий час, а пізніше ви можете просто покласти
їх у папір і носити з собою так,
дякую,
дякую за чудову ідею, а також
будьте обережні з какао-порошком,
якщо збираєтеся  додати багато какао-
порошку. Какао-порошок дає нам багато о
енергія, тому не їжте ці цукерки ближче
до кінця дня, будьте обережні з
цим, дякую за всі ваші
поради, добре, тепер давайте переглянемо
різні фігури, які ми робимо сьогодні, щоб
ви знову бачили зображення на екрані,
щоб  хлопці, пора п'яти чотири години
чаю 5:00 чай у вас є UT по-
англійськи так, звичайно,
Ерл Грей мій улюблений, і ви додаєте
до нього молоко іноді не завжди, але
іноді так,
коли у мене є Ерл Грей, я завжди  додайте дві
чайні ложки молока, це також чудовий рецепт
, тому, хлопці, перед тим, як ви будете мати, ви можете
зробити з чашкою чаю, будь ласка,
виконайте домашнє завдання, яке полягатиме в тому, щоб
прикрасити коробку та підготувати коробку
для цукерок, які ви можете подавати
подарунок своїм друзям, тож гарного
дня і до наступної зустрічі дякую
дуже до побачення насолоджуйтесь чаєм дякую
[Музика]